let's talk about these stories that we
pulled up
we got uh one from the new york post
mind the tornado above us friends i
apologize
from new york post
espn star jason whitlock blasts disney
for feminizing sports
i yes and i think this is gonna this is
gonna be uh this will play a role
in the upcoming elections in that
you've got what's happening with the
ncaa swimming with uh with leah thomas
and i know i've been critical of people
who refuse to speak up saying if you're
not speaking up publicly how can i
defend you because people will just say
nobody's mad about this what are you
complaining about if you can't stand up
for yourself but i will say at the very
least these people will be secret trump
voters like we saw in 2016 and 2020 a
large percentage of people who would not
admit it but once they get into the
polling booth they look around look over
their shoulders and then hit trump a
million times the history of things like
that voting it's it's secret for a
reason because that's a natural part of
people's minds when they see crap out
there they don't want to have to stand
up and say it but they're going to vote
the way they feel
see the lights flicker there
how did the lights flicker we're on
independent electricity oh magnetic
fields well so so jason let's talk about
this uh your take on the feminization of
sports well
i think a lot of people it kind of went
over their heads in 1996 when
disney acquired abc and espn
and and that once you start
once you're taken over by disney you now
disney's going to promote its values
there's no
greater
cultural force
than perhaps disney across the entire
globe
and
so i think disney came in with an agenda
i think in 1994 disney tried to acquire
nbc
couldn't
nbc at that time had the nba broadcast
disney has wanted to get into sports
lane they got into the sports lane with
espn because they understand anybody in
the entertainment field
entertainment industry understands that
live sports is the most valuable asset
for attracting a massive audience and
being able to preach your values to a
massive audience
particularly in this now dvr
watch stuff when you want to
era that we're in live sports is the
only thing where people sit down and
watch it as it happens live and so they
wanted espn they wanted in the sports
world and they wanted to apply their
values their culture to the sports world
and that's what has happened and i think
disney
based on their attack on young kids and
the sexuality and the gender thing
disney believes in the matriarchy disney
believes in the uprooting of the
patriarchy disney is very feminist
and
uh they've applied all those values to
espn which is the worldwide leader in
sports and that's why if you just look
at sports over the last 25 30 years
since disney has owned espn sports have
just become softer and more feminized i
i actually
i spoke about this in 2018
when we were seeing
culture you know uh video games movies
seeing all the woke influx i said it's
gonna be real crazy when the nfl the nba
and major league sports start being
forced to adopt these things
and we're starting to see it you know we
spoke with uh jonathan isaac that dude's
awesome yeah and he was talking about
how he didn't want to kneel for black
lives matter people got mad at him about
it so we had a meeting we said we're
going to do this and he was like i don't
believe in it though the crazy thing is
here's a guy
you got colin kaepernick who kneels
he gets ragged on for it well he brought
politics into the game i understand why
people might be mad about that well the
politics there starts spreading to
everyone kneeling and now you got a guy
jonathan isaac being like i just don't
want to kneel i don't mind if you do and
they're mad at him because he won't bend
the knee
you see
i think i think
and just keep in mind everybody on espn
the worldwide leader in sports is
criticizing jonathan isaac and any and
lord behold take drew brees the
quarterback for the saints makes this
comment basically defending the national
anthem and he gets assassinated his
character does by everybody on espn like
he's some racist pig because
the national anthem means something to
him means something to people in his
family that were in the service
and so that's
these athletes are being bullied into
kneeling and adopting these values we're
actually uh this sunday we got a special
episode we we did a podcast with ben and
uh ben shapiro and jonathan jonathan
isaac uh separately
but um you know he was saying that he
doesn't think these people
believe in in the message that the
players are just kind of you know
they're told they have to do it and
they're like okay whatever i guess
and uh you know many of them probably
outright
just don't like these values i think the
reality is a lot of people are
christians i think a lot of people like
families
what worries me is why aren't there more
people like you know isaac who are gonna
just very calmly and passionately say
look i believe in my country uh no
disrespect to those who protest i'm
gonna do my thing why can't we at least
have more players like that i imagine
it's because the paychecks are so big
those guys they make so much money that
i mean how how can you turn away from 90
million dollar contract 10 million
dollar contract over three years or four
years or whatever they make what's an
average contract in the nba right now
probably five
to eight million dollars but but wait
for like your average player for how
many years
you know what what about your rate of
five years what about your lowest tier
player like the modest tiers player is
probably making 800 900 000.
but but
let's take the big money people out of
it just talking to colin before the show
working in academia and i talked about
this today
about just corporate america in general
if you want to move up in leadership at
any major corporation if you don't adopt
the
values of diversity inclusion and equity
if you don't hop on board with all the
lgbt stuff if if you don't swallow it
you can't move up
or you get run out of academia
yeah it's the same principles are
applied that you see the pressure in the
sports world is even more intense these
guys have guaranteed contracts and have
genera have made generational wealth
what if you're just the guy that works
at
name the company or disney or anywhere
that doesn't want to hop on board
with these values you get one out you
can't move up yeah it's the same same
dynamic that's taking place you know in
sports in academia i mean it's it's like
this spiral of silence they go into
where everyone else is doing this one
signal and if you have areas that tend
to be you know politically skewed in a
certain direction like academia as a
signal that might have started out with
like you know oh i'm just putting my
pronoun in my email signature or in my
social media bio these soon rather than
just being a signal of like oh i'm just
inclusive it then becomes the people who
don't have
these little things in their bios and
their email signatures that becomes a
tell because once it gets so popular
then the person who doesn't do it is the
one that stands out and now the sudden
people can question them and you know
what are you doing i'm interested in
your experience you're an evolutionary
biologist like with the with the i guess
you would call it the the emergence or
the the mainstreamism of the transgender
movement or i don't know what's called a
movement but just this whole like what's
it like in the science community when
you're discussing biology i've got a
story or where you can say well no i
just i just want to
kind of pull back a little bit what you
were saying and merge these kind of
these conversations you know we're
talking about the feminization of sports
we've got someone you're a biologist
yeah well so let's let's talk about
what's happening with you know you can
define a woman
well exactly exactly so
you know
i think we'll get to that in a second
but let's let's kind of merge that as a
biologist witnessing what's happening in
sports with the ncaa and all that stuff
what's what's your take and what what do
you have to say for you know what's
happening like what's your view on it
yeah i mean it's the same same dynamic
and it just requires people to feel like
they're comfortable enough by seeing
other people who are speaking up and not
getting canceled to have them speak up i
mean when i was in academia there was no
one talking about the stuff i was
talking about i was one of the first
people to be like
actually there are only two sexes it's
not a spectrum it's not a social
construct and i mean that was all the
arrows hit me at once and that's a
signal to everyone
to you know who thinks the same way i do
that they're not going to say anything
because they see what that's how it
happens when the one vocal person comes
up and so it's that chilling effect and
i think that's playing out in sports is
that chilling effect when someone gets
hammered in the media for their
reasonable opinion that just sends a
signal to everyone else like oh this is
a third rail i'm not gonna i'm not even
gonna go there what what is this
right we all of a sudden we have
academia
terrified we have
one of the most lucrative and
high-paying industries major major
sports and they are terrified of this
ideology
well because they know they can get
cancelled they know it's a tool yeah
that they can get run out of their jobs
and have to go independent the way that
colin has i i do want to and i don't
want to speak for tim but i do think
what tim was asking you quite honestly
was like
we had a man leah thomas william thomas
swimming against women i was getting in
the ivy oh you were and yeah that's what
he's like as a biologist
what is your take this is crazy to us
well so it's completely yeah it's it's
completely insane i mean
so the the thing that's underpinning all
of it is this like this gender ideology
that is saying that
what a man or a woman or a boy and a
girl is has nothing to do with your
biology your your reproductive organs or
anything it has everything to do with
just your internal sense of of who you
are or your identification with social
roles and stereotypes of like
masculinity or femininity that's
literally what they think is is a man or
a woman which really goes against what
we've been hearing feminists say for so
long that you know a woman can behave
any way they want to and still be a
woman you can be a masculine woman you
can be a feminine woman you can be a
feminine man you can be a masculine man
but you're you're fundamentally defined
as a manner when by your your
reproductive anatomy
somehow this ideology has just taken
root i think a lot of it's because you
see these big organizations like the
aclu like the human rights campaign they
had all this fun all the all this
funding billions of dollars going into
something like getting gay marriage
passed which i personally think is a
good it was a good thing to get past but
once they get that big victory
what do they do next they're set up in a
situation where
they need to find something else to put
all this money into they have all these
donors they have they're not just going
to turn their lights off shutter the
windows and say like well we won time to
time to go home there's no more big
dragons to slay and if you look at where
the funding went in these organizations
it used to be all going into gay
marriage and then was it 2014 or 15 when
it became federally legal or not yeah
then you see the narrative switch to
trans everything and it's this gender
ideology and it's this built-in
apparatus with billions of dollars
behind it that is just shunting this
money into point five percent of the
population and
we have no response to it we haven't
built up the organizations to respond to
this thing now that isn't the next i
used to work on
i used to work in non-profits i did
fundraising
and this
was one of the things i witnessed a good
non-profit should put itself out of
business yeah if you say hey we got it
we got an issue with uh there's not
enough panda bears
well you know maybe in 20 30 years all
of a sudden panda bears are no longer
endangered anymore what does the
non-profit do
waves goodbye to everybody and says
mission accomplished this was the goal
we saved their band what what these
organizations will do is they'll say
well it was never about the pandas what
about the kangaroo
what about this new songbird they don't
want to cease to exist they're they're
they
they they like the power they've accrued
they transition well and then they look
at people on their that they're paying
people they have paychecks they have a
you know they they have a video god
bless you
exactly i think greenpeace is a good
example of this i briefly worked for
greenpeace and the one thing i didn't
understand and i started uh looking at
um
i think uh what what's what's the lady
do you know the guy the greenpeace guy's
name doctor is it it's not it's not i
think it's patrick moore right yeah
we're gonna have him i think yeah maybe
yeah um i know there's also a paul
watson who left and he's the the sea
shepherds guy but um i believe patrick
moore's name can you guys check
because he's pro-nuclear power oh yeah
and so he's been very vocal on similar
issues as us yeah patrick moore patrick
moore so greenpeace it starts because
they're opposing nuclear testing i
respect that i don't like the nuclear
bombs being tested and the devastating
effects it blanketed this planet with
radioactive particles that interferes
with scientific instruments so there's
yeah it's not good that everybody on the
planet was blowing things up to test
things and so they oppose it and they
would do things like send out boats into
the area so they couldn't conduct tests
and i'm like i dig it now they're saying
nuclear energy is bad why in my personal
opinion because nuclear is a scary word
it allows them to keep the the company
going and make money and there's reasons
why people like patrick moore leave
because they're like you're off mission
this is not what we're supposed to be
doing
these non-profits i agree i think it's a
really important point that often
doesn't get brought up
they they uh i remember
i was working for a nonprofit at
fundraising and one of the one of the
organizations they were fundraising on
behalf of was the human rights campaign
the hrc
apparently and i could be getting this
wrong i was not high up or anything but
uh there was a conversation where there
are a few organizations that were
rejecting some bill because it granted
certain rights to
lgb people but not
t people
and so the human rights campaign was
like we're going to go for this because
it's a win these other organizations
were like no you know you shouldn't
so there was a point where they were
willing to outright be like we will
advocate for laws that do not protect
this group of people i wonder now if
it's just part of the the process that
once you get certain laws passed
now you can move on to your next mission
and make sure the money keeps flowing
you need more scare tactics i think i i
think you hit the nail on the head with
a large portion of what we're seeing
activism can't stop there's money to be
made this is why we're focusing on
microaggressions now we've ran out of
macro ones yep we skipped the dentist
deci aggressions and we're going to be
moving on to
aggressions next i think we run out of
we
have a very short supply of racism
and so now racism
is
oh you didn't call me by my property i
think we just had a baseball player
uh a baseball first base coach i think
just yesterday for the san francisco
giants
he got called a mf i'm i can say
[ __ ] probably on this show
we do try to be family friendly but
we're not going to we're not going to
cry about this
he got called an mf
and he said that when he when the guy
said it it reeked of racism what i
didn't know
literally
so because there's such a short supply
of racism we've had to expand what is
racism and so now if in the heat of a
sports battle if you call someone an mf
and they happen to be black and you
happen to be white that reeks of racism
i
i want to
if i can and i think i can do this on
this show not because i think you guys
are going to agree with me but i just
want to say it because colin said
something interesting and tim you push
me back in line if i'm taking the
conversation somewhere you don't want it
to go but tim said or colin said that
you agreed with same-sex marriage and
thought it was a good thing
i have to sit here and say i disagree
with that and and not because i have a
problem with the lgbt crowd the gay
crowd or whatever i think we've moved in
the society where we think everything is
for everybody
and i don't think everything is for
everybody
tim's genes they're not for me so i
should not try to squeeze into them and
i don't think there was a long period in
my life where
i was very irresponsible
in my dating and sexual life and i was
never in the right mindset to be married
marriage wasn't for me i had no control
over and so i think we've moved to where
we just we want to make everything for
everybody and so i i i think my sexual
promiscuity
no different than
same-sex attraction it makes me not an
ideal candidate for marriage i i i agree
with the majority of the sentiment that
not everything is for everybody and
absolutely it seems like you know they
it's like the sarcastic ball in south
park where they make all the kids wear
the goofy things and the football
becomes a balloon when you try to make
everything equal then you know what do
you do you got to cut off the tall grass
however when i when i look at the issue
of gay marriage i agree with colin i
think it was it this is an interesting
conversation i think it's good um i
think it's good in the sense that
lgbtqia plus people
should not be discriminated against
based on those characteristics
there's questions in what that means
when it manifests like who gets right
who gets access to specific spaces like
women's only spaces does that mean
female or otherwise i think that's part
of the conversation we have but i mean
like you can't throw someone out of your
business for specific reasons you know
like we want to be public accommodations
should be equal to all and we should we
should have this is my view it's the
more liberal view i suppose but i i
think that if you're a part of society
you're paying taxes and we're all
funding this machine then
you should be able to accommodate
someone and not arbitrarily like i don't
like the way you look so get out but
within certain uh
within reason you can still do that
anyway you can give someone no reason
and say oh you said a naughty word and
so i have the right to refuse service to
anybody it becomes increasingly
impossible to actually maintain control
of people's views and opinions but
anyway just to the point of uh gay
marriage
the question i had
when prop 8 was happening i think it was
in california was isn't marriage
specifically an abrahamic institution
which is rooted in going to the church
and saying vows before god
if that's the case then i don't believe
it is appropriate for the state to
mandate what the church does however if
the state recognizes marriage as some
legal contract with legal ramifications
those must be granted to to to anybody
now there are certainly questions about
you know what the writers brought up
polygamy and things like that and i'm
like well there was polygamy a long time
ago it's not here now we're just talking
about cultural shifts and cultural
changes but if there are two people who
love each other
and this is the current standard we're
in i think you know lgbtqia plus they
should be able to get married and and
live together and they should have all
of the tax rights and legal rights i i
don't want to hear another story about
you know two men who love each other and
one guy gets sick and his his husband
isn't allowed to go in and see him as
he's dying that's a horrifying story
because it it's a man and his brother
you know his brother gets cancer he can
go in and see him these two guys spend
their whole lives together they love
each other look i i don't think that's
any of my business
one one of the things that arises that's
changing everything
is going after kids
right
i'm not saying you know i think if
there's a teacher in a school who's gay
and a kid walks up and sees a picture
and says who's that the teacher can say
that's my husband
and the kid can say but you're but
you're a boy how do you have a husband
the teacher should then say well maybe
you'll learn more about this when you're
older ask your parents it's really that
simple when they start saying they want
mandatory education on very specific
things where some of these books have
been particularly graphic that's when
i'm like yo we are not talking about
civil rights for an individual we are
not talking about me saying i want to
make sure that the people i know and
care about are able to be there for
their loved ones we're talking about
going to kids and explaining in detail
five to nine year olds
serious adult things that it should not
be up to them it should be up to the
parents and sometimes there might be
parents who are like my six-year-old is
ready okay well i personally disagree i
think six is a bit too young you should
maybe wait till they're getting closer
to puberty but i'm not the parent so
there are still limitations to where we
as a society have to decide what is
abuse and what isn't
talking about marriage a little bit i
think you make a really good point
you've got to define what it is and what
it means i think that um in the church
it's a union of be under god essentially
and i'm not 100 familiar but it's really
about like like a like a almost like a
magical union with your soul but then
when you talk about marriage in the
state it's just a business contract and
the way i look at it in at this current
state is it's i'm treating like a
business contract i want to give my wife
money my girlfriend and i don't want to
get taxed on it so i'm going to marry
her so i can give her a bunch of money
uh and and stop my love for her is
irrelevant it's a it's a it's just a
business deal um but i'm interested how
you guys and i hope that i think that
that's maybe the conversation people in
society should have when discussing who
should be able to do what when it
pertains to marriage and what it
actually means and then and people
sometimes you'll say like well civil
union then you get all the all the all
the digital rights without calling it
marriage but then they're like no i want
to label it the same i want to be
treated the same they start getting
identity politics
i think what jason was saying earlier
and what you were getting at was a sort
of slippery slope you get into
where like you have a movement like the
lgbt
q plus ia2 whatever and the reason that
number that those letters keep expanding
is because they've defined themselves by
we're the most inclusive
group ever we're going to just accept
anyone who's
atypical what any any axis you can
imagine
and
that leads to them not being able to
just really
push out the fringes of the people that
really shouldn't be part of their groups
you know like there are some
organizations that will want to add the
p which is the pedophile to like these
types of groups the p is silent and they
can't police their borders because
they've just we're so inclusive it's an
orientation and
by that like they need to be able to
police their border to some degree
because
some people are just
bad people some people
in certain ideologies as well
you could mean police have you guys
for sure thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you